hello my name is amber and i'm rod and
we're from christchurch new zealand
we're on a family trip to europe we've
been to england scotland and france and
now we're in germany we're in rue de
shine to explore the wonderful rhine
valley come and explore british home
with us
they're playing music
i can't believe it there is so many
people here dad it's extremely busy
isn't it darling but it shows how
popular it is with tourists it's lovely
it's so quaint
compared to new zealand it's just you
know all the history that is here
the beautiful buildings
this is fun
hello good morning good morning welcome
in siegfried's mechanical music
experience
this is absolutely amazing dad
we wanted to visit this place because we
heard that it's got a wonderful
collection of musical or mechanical
musical instruments that were made over
the last 300 years and it's very special
for amber because she loves music
and plays musical instruments absolutely
loves music
daddy look at the organ
this is making lovely music daddy
my please do you think you're that good
okay
come on sweetheart now we're taking a
boat trip on the rhine let's go
come on dead hurry up
it's lovely to be here on this this
river knowing that
over the last you know 2 000 years
humanity has also come along this
waterway and to be you know to be here
and to be part of
to be part of that is just
an amazing experience
i love just looking at all these build
old buildings and the churches and the
castles like that one and i love the
bricks how they put the bricks into it
and um
i just wonder how they actually put got
all the bricks actually up there
dirty here we are on goblins
here we are almost at dorchester almost
at the german corner
where the merzel flows into the rhine
wow amber look at that
it's hugely impressive to be here it's
very important to for german history
this corner it's far bigger than i
expected it to be
and now here's a picture of amber in
front of both rivers the rhine and the
merzel
i think it's really cold
okay this is the end of our
tour of the rhine valley the boat trip
along the rhine reutershire where we
started coblin's where we've ended
i hope you've enjoyed the ride like we
have um but it's been a very long day
for us so we need a nap yeah
juice goodbye